you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
clean energy or dirty fuel the debate
over biomass heats up
tiny islands big energy how orkney's
windy location is driving a green
revolution
and we look at the new technology
helping airlines reduce
their carbon footprint
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions now new plans by a uk power
plant
could increase carbon emissions and
household bills
despite being designed to capture
pollution analysis by
energy think tank ember has found plans
to fit carbon capture technology
at the drax plant could cost british
taxpayers nearly 32 billion
pounds over the next 25 years and there
are already concerns about the power
station's
choice of energy source biomass forms an
important part of the uk's low-carbon
energy mix and is officially classified
as renewable but that classification is
somewhat controversial
so what is biomass and how is it used
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well let's bring in dr mai bowie senior
research associate at the center for
environmental policy at imperial college
london
welcome to you now ember's report says
that drax's plans will be hugely costly
to the taxpayer through subsidies but
how good an environmental
project is this let's talk about the
biomass element of it
just how green is it as a source of
energy
so with bioenergy you can kind of do
this quite well or also do it quite
poorly
so it's really important and the trick
is to kind of do the analysis to make
sure that you
pick the right sort of cleanest and
cost-effective approach
and there's a range of different bio
energy sources that you can use and i
think the solution will vary depending
on the types
that you you kind of select so i think
in terms of the cost that also varies a
lot because of the different choices
that we use and i think
there are ways to do it through
engineering and
economics to try to calculate the sort
of most effective approach
and the plan here is to fit the wood
burning plant with carbon capture
technology and they say this will make
it a carbon negative
power generator do you agree that that's
possible
yes i believe so so this is based on a
lot of the work that we've done here at
imperial college
um there are sort of pathways in order
to get a negative or carbon negative
solution and and this depends on how you
kind of
approach the supply chain of your
biomass so making sure you choose the
biomass that has the lowest carbon
footprint
and also trying to maximize the
efficiency of the plant and the process
and so with the co2 capture technologies
you can capture a very
large proportion of that carbon dioxide
so from 90
and some studies are now showing you can
capture even 99
of that carbon so a lot of if you
capture
them the most carbon was possible then
you can try to maximize that negative
emission
um to offset those uh the sort of carbon
footprint
dr mai bowie thanks very much indeed
and you can see a more detailed
breakdown of the real-time
power mix including just how much
electricity is coming from sources
including biomass anytime you like just
head to
skynews.com climate
in today's other climate news the uk is
falling behind
eu countries in the race to decarbonize
the steel industry
that's according to the energy and
climate intelligence unit
it says the uk only has vague proposals
for switching to hydrogen-based steel
production
which is believed to be the optimal
route to decarbonize the industry
a number of eu countries are already
using hydrogen as fuel while the uk
is not expected to fund any projects
until 2023
new research suggests more than half of
the uk's offshore energy jobs will be in
the low
carbon industry by 2030. a study by the
robert gordon university has found the
uk's legacy as a leading
offshore oil and gas hub will be
surpassed by renewable sectors
which could support up to 130 000 green
jobs while many organizations have
committed to reach net zero in the
coming decades
q royal botanic gardens have gone beyond
that
and pledged to become climate positive
by 2030.
the company's sustainability strategy
aims to go further than carbon neutral
and capture more carbon than it emits by
investing in nature-based carbon sinks
as well as operating sustainably
now if you want to see the much-promised
green revolution in action
look no further than orkney once utterly
reliant on fossil fuels it's now home to
more domestic wind turbines
than any other county and produces more
energy than it can use
well today the duke and duchess of
cambridge have visited the european
marine energy center
to see the work that they've been doing
it's the beginning of a week-long tour
of scotland which will host the cop 26
summit
in november sky's rhiannon mills has the
latest from kirkwall
well what you quickly find out is how
passionate people are here they talk
about being surrounded by renewable
energy
sources since they were kids and they
are genuinely connected to their natural
environment but for william and kate i
think
the big thing today has been drawing a
focus on how orkney is
a world leader you have to remember that
since 2003 the european marine energy
center has been based here
so it means that all of the world's
technology when it comes to wave and
tidal power
harnessing the energy from the sea has
largely been tested here
in the waters also what's fascinating
with orkney is that
since 2013 100
of the electricity requirements here has
been met by
renewable sources the problem is though
they create
so much energy from the likes of wind
turbines
that that doesn't go back into the grid
the grid can't cope with it so it's what
they do with it
and so what they've been doing is
producing hydrogen
and that's where the fascinating bit for
the future comes in the projects they're
looking at so
potentially using hydrogen to power the
likes of fairies to heat people's homes
even feed it back into industry so
things like distilling gin
and whiskey so for many people as we
head towards cop 26 they genuinely see
orkney as a living laboratory that the
world can really learn from
projects funded by uk financial
institutions are responsible for almost
twice
britain's annual carbon emissions that's
according to a new report published by
greenpeace and wwf
they say that while countries are
setting ambitious emissions reduction
targets there's no such requirement
for the financial sector so let's take a
look at their findings well these are
the countries responsible
for emitting the most greenhouse gases
in 2018. and as you can see
china really leads the way there
emitting around 11 billion tons of
carbon dioxide equivalent followed by
the united states
and then india now the uk emits far less
meaning it didn't even make the top ten
there
well the study estimates that if the
city of london was ranked as a country
it would be the ninth largest emitter in
the world now that's based on analysis
that looks at investments made by 15
major
uk banks and 10 asset managers it
suggests
they were responsible for 805 million
tonnes of carbon dioxide equivalent
in 2019. well let's bring in our
business presenter ian king and in this
report suggests that the uk
financial firms are responsible for an
enormous amount of emissions but is it
as simple
as blaming the city do you think no it's
not as simple as that and i think quite
frankly the methodology that's been
deployed here is a bit silly i think
this whole study is a bit of a gimmick a
bit of a
publicity stunt if you like but it's
worked because we are talking about it
i mean one of the problems here is that
they're confusing financing
with consumption or financing with
production of emissions i think you have
to take into account that there's
presumably some element of double
counting
involved here unless they're going to
assume that if the uh financier who's
ultimately responsible for
a mission is then presumably the
individual the company that uh
produces that emission ultimately is not
to blame for that so i think you have to
take into account
things like that nonetheless i think the
report does throw into relief the whole
debate that's going on here
in the city there is no doubt that
investors are taking esg environmental
social and governance issues a lot more
seriously
environmental obviously gets lumped in
with those two though they're not
always related but it's a big big area
of investment a big area of debate right
now
ian thanks now the uk met office says
its advanced weather forecasting can
help make flying
more efficient the high-resolution wind
data
is already helping airlines like
norwegian reduce their carbon emissions
and here's how the new technology
developed by swedish company avtec
aims to replace the standard weather
data
sent every nine minutes to a plane in
flight
now it's based on high resolution data
sent at the pilot's request
from the met office every minute during
the cruising phase of a flight
now the data takes into account the
latest weather conditions as well as the
plane's weight
distance altitude and its speed and it
calculates the best altitude for the
plane
to take advantage of trailing winds and
taking the faster path
means using less fuel now norwegian
airlines has started using the system
and it's estimated that it's saving up
to 15
000 tonnes of co2 a year now that's the
equivalent
of the greenhouse gas emissions of
driving 31 million miles
in a passenger car well joining me now
is stig pati a pilot with norwegian
air hello to you so just how much
difference can this
very detailed forecasting data make to
flight
efficiency and lower emissions
well as you mentioned we save about 15
000
tons co2 per year and it's about 1.6
percentage
and for the pilots they can also see
actually what they can take
for action today they get a nice
printout with all the details so they
can see
on this particular flight we can save
300 kilograms of
co2 we can save 60 seconds of time so it
makes it very concrete and easily
actionable for the for the pilots
williamson how much difference does it
make to a pilot's job
in terms of pre-flight preparation and
as well as actually flying the plane
well the pre-flight preparation is a
separate task they are done
as you say pre-flight and and then this
weather data
high resolution data from the uk met
office is brought to the aircraft in
real time when the aircraft is up
in the air and then they can make last
minute uh updates to the routing based
on that
uh data and it's it's much more accurate
in in the
density of the data as well as it's in
real time
stick patty thanks very much indeed well
that's everything from us for today
coming up next time big oil on trial a
dutch court will decide if shell is
legally responsible for climate change
you can find out more here on the daily
climate show at the same time tomorrow
thanks for watching see you then